foreign
could you describe what you did with
Will Smith
how it came to be and your personal
primary Lessons Learned doesn't have to
be from the content of the book it could
also be from the interactions exposure
to La entertainment Etc just love to
know
what you did for people who don't know
yeah how it happened maybe those are in
the opposite order and then
what your personal
primary Lessons Learned work from that
so I co-authored Will Smith's Memoir
which came out last year it's called
will
we worked on it for about
I think about two and a half years
together
the way it came about was his team
actually reached out to me he had wanted
to do a book for a little while and
from what I understood I wasn't there
but from what I understand he had you
know some kind of casual meetings with a
few different authors
just to kind of see what was out there
and
when they contacted me about it
first of all another story of my agent
being great my agent didn't tell me
about it right away the first thing she
did is she sent me an email and she said
hypothetical question if a celebrity
wanted to write a book with you
on what terms would you be interested
which is smart because she didn't tell
me who it was yeah it's smart
and I said it would have to be an
a-lister
and they would have to want it to be
more than
just about their life like they would
want to like dig into their problems and
history and baggage
Etc
which is as it so happens exactly what
will wanted to do
so
after that we set up the meeting
super surreal I don't know I always tell
people like
the craziest part
about meeting a really really famous
person isn't actually the really really
famous person it's all the [ __ ] that
goes on around the super famous person
it's hard to explain but next thing I
know I'm getting whisked away to
Atlanta where I'm supposed to meet him
on set
of a film that he's working on turns out
Ang Lee is working is directing that
film so I start like don't Fanboy at
angli don't Fanboy Will Smith like oh
God like this is so stressful and you're
supposed to just kind of act casual like
this is all normal so he he finishes
there like rehearsing a scene or
something and I'm like I'm like walking
in circles not knowing where you're
supposed to go and
his people are like are you okay and I'm
like where should I sit I've never been
on a Hollywood set before like what do I
do with my hands what do I do with my
hands like Ricky Bobby
I told one of his managers I was like
I've never been on a Hollywood set
before I don't know if I'm like in the
right place or not she just kind of
looked at me like really I was like
sorry
you know so next thing I know they
finished rehearsing we go straight to an
airstrip getting loaded onto a private
jet and they're like no no you need to
sit in the front with will because
you're gonna talk about the book now and
I'm like now like this is okay you know
first time on a jet so the whole thing
is just surreal and strange and
everywhere he goes there's a mob of fans
waiting for him people shrieking
so it took a few days to kind of like
Get over that get in a room with him
privately where it's quiet and actually
have kind of an extended one-on-one
conversation with him and
before I went to meet him I had two
conditions for myself which was the
first one is he can't be an [ __ ]
because I just
nothing is no amount of money no matter
Prestige is worth spending three years
working with an [ __ ]
and then two was you know there needs to
be something legitimately like he
everything needs to be on the table he
needs to be very willing to open up and
kind of go anywhere so we had a few
really good productive conversations and
I was blown away the thing that
really knock my socks off about him
I mean he's a smart guy obviously he's a
very hard-working guy obviously
his charisma
in his ability to read a room and react
in a way that makes people feel
comfortable
and then also kind of talk it to him a
little bit about some of the the hurdles
that he went through in his life his
ability to adapt to set back
to reframe it in a way that is helpful
to himself
it it it's really incredible like he
he's one of the and I know this seems
strange to say after the Oscars incident
but he really is one of the most
emotionally intelligent people that I've
been around
and so we had a dinner the last night
and he kind of just out of the blue was
like so what's up Mark we gonna do a
book or what and I was like well I've
got an outline in mind and I said
you know I told him the thing I just
said about emotions and his ability to
use his emotions to adapt to things I
also said it's probably why he's such a
good actor is that it's he's able to
summon emotions and play with them and
react to them in a masterful way
and I said so I think the book should be
built around emotion it starts with fear
it moves through all your defense
mechanisms into your Fame into all the
success until
that facade collapsing and then
eventually finally ends up at at love at
a very genuine authentic love which is
kind of something that it took him a
long time to get to
and I said in As you move through all
those emotions there's there's a word
for somebody who's able to move through
setbacks and and deal with any sort of
negative emotion and harness it
to Advantage them and I said it's it's
will so that should be the name of the
book
and it was like the Fresh Prince came
back like he was just like hell yeah he
like gets up starts like slamming stuff
on the table he's like hell yeah hell
yeah we're doing that and I'm like all
right so I got the gig like
it was a good meeting good meeting yeah
good meeting good meeting
but it was a wild and fun two years with
him
he
is honestly I mean as you can imagine I
get
so many questions
since
March about him
but honestly he's
such a great guy deep down obviously he
makes mistakes and does stupid things
like the rest of us but
I have nothing but gratitude for that
project it was very easy to write it was
very enjoyable the way we did it was
I presented the outline we kind of
refined it together
I wrote the first draft
he did a revision of that and then me
and the editor at penguin kind of like
did a final pass
so it really is both of us in that book
like it's a lot of people assume it was
all me or assume it was all him I don't
know but like it really was both of us
like he put a lot of work and effort
into it and he really cared about it
so I'm going to ask about what you
learned about Hollywood and
entertainment through the process of
interacting with him and
writing the book
I'll just open a door if you want to
walk through it if not we can skip it I
know you just mentioned a lot of people
have asked you about the Oscars and
Chris Rock incident and so on is there
anything you want to say about that or
about him with respect to that or not
you can also just say nope not really
and we can move on totally up to you so
I I publicly wrote a piece about it
as a newsletter it's on my website
the tldr of it is basically
yeah he did something really stupid and
unacceptable but as somebody who spent a
lot of time around him not just him his
family his friends
getting to know his kids getting to know
his brother
he is honestly there is so much
generosity that happens with him that
nobody ever sees and it's very much by
Design like he doesn't
he doesn't feel a need to publicize it
and so just seeing what I've seen being
around him
I kind of
told people to like look
that's not the real him that's like the
worst side of him you know the will that
you know and that you hope is real is
that's the real will he's he's a very
great
loving but flawed human being
in terms of what I learned oh and you
asked earlier what I learned from him
it's funny because that project I didn't
you know he he does have a marvelous
story of resilience and overcoming I
mean he comes he comes from a very
dysfunctional family an abusive father
grew up on the streets of West Philly
like very rough neighborhoods
and it's it's actually very remarkable
how he navigated that
avoided all the pitfalls that come with
that sort of upbringing to get where he
is today it's definitely not an accident
so that story is amazing but there was
nothing in it that really
you know there were no epiphanies for me
personally the epiphanies for me
personally were just being around him as
a professional you know being around a
guy like that who's been at the top of
his game top of his field for 30 years
one of the most famous human beings on
the planet
I was blown away at the way he
worked with his team
the way he was with his fans the way he
dealt with the media
I mean to be honest dude like I the
first time I hung out with him and I saw
him get mobbed by fans my immediate
reaction was like man I should be nicer
to my fans like I think will is nicer to
his fans than I am and and like he's he
is he's Will Smith like yeah he's
paddling out through 100 foot waves
every time he steps yes out of a door
yeah but one of the things that he he
helped me see
and he he said this to me too is he said
you know he was like I'm very aware that
every encounter I have
with a fan is a very asymmetric
encounter like for me it's five seconds
that I'm gonna forget about
you know within a minute
for them it's five seconds they're gonna
remember for the rest of their lives so
he's like
just put in the effort for those five
seconds like it's not the payoff is so
Monumental for the other person that it
there's kind of no
ethical argument to not do it
the other thing that he said that was
really profound for me because as you
can imagine he's got this like full
staff of people that just follow him
around the world he's got cooks and
chefs and
wardrobe people and
Security Guys and everything Logistics
and I asked him once I was like do you
ever feel like it's kind of weird
just having this like
team of people that just Shadow you
everywhere you go cook your you know I
was like when was the last time you
cooked a meal for yourself and he like
started laughing and he's like I don't
know man probably at least 10 years
but he told me he said he's like look
it's really simple like I I am world
class at one thing
and
yeah it'd be very easy for me to like be
the humble guy and cook a meal for
myself and send the chef home
but
I'm only world class at one thing and
that would take away from my time and
energy from being world class at that
one thing and not only that but my chef
is world class at one thing
and by sending him home I am taking away
from his ability to be world class at
the thing that he's world class at
that's cool yeah
I saw potentially the first part coming
but not the second part yeah that's
that's a significant
addition right looking through
the mirror from the other direction not
just your direction and he described it
as robbing him of an opportunity to be
excellent which I just to me it was like
such a beautiful
it's funny because you know you hear so
many Outsourcing conversations in terms
of business of like how to hire and
Outsource and do all this and automate
and do all this stuff he spoke about it
in ethical terms which
who was really profound for me